before I kick off this talk can I just
ask by way of a show of hands is anybody
here who's ever cried at a film oh
that's quite a lot of people okay lovely
it's a few resistors over there
obviously come we've all seen up thank
you
great can we now have again by way of a
show of hands anybody remembers a story
they were told as a child all right
there's a lot of people there that's
nearly everyone great thank you very
much and maybe again just hands up if
you'd like to calculate the volumes of
composite solids anybody know okay well
that comes as no surprise to me and I'm
a math teacher
so social really come as no surprise to
you the truth is we've been thinking
about stories and telling stories to
each other for a lot longer than we'd be
thinking about mathematics I've been
really lucky in my career I've been able
to write films and direct plays and to
teach maths it's amazing at dinner
parties no one ever asks you what it's
like to be a maths teacher projectit
here behind me we've got some video from
a great study by Heider and Simmel in
1944 you can see as it's going around
see these triangles here oh what's
happening here or the big one he is not
happy he's not happy at all always quite
quite aggressive in the circle seems to
be sneaking back in and we see the
little ones getting getting rather
chased away there he's not happy at all
and the circle in fact looks quite
nervous locked away and once he secured
his territory there's the big circle
going into the house
and the the big triangle the circle is
is petrified look in the corner there oh
I can absolutely mad absolutely mad of
course that's a fiction that's a fiction
because triangles don't have emotions
but it just seems that we can't help to
see these shapes with emotions with
personalities with desires
it's almost as though human beings are
hard-wired to see those things around us
in emotional ways that we relate to
hardwired for sympathy and it's this
innate ability to sympathize with our
surroundings that makes humans such
great storytellers such great consumers
of stories you may have heard it said
that every story falls into one of seven
archetypes but then you might have heard
it said that every story falls into one
of 36 archetypes or maybe one of two but
when I was learning to write plays I was
taught there's only one story ever told
it goes something like this the main
character that's the protagonist and he
could tell it's important it's in Greek
he's got desires ambitions something to
aim for
but obstacles stand in the way of him
achieving that now our protagonist goes
on a journey either a physical journey
or an emotional journey and then one of
two things can happen either he can
overcome those obstacles and get what he
wants and our stalker calls that comedy
or he could fail to overcome those
obstacles and not get what he wants and
Aristotle called that tragedy it's a
really simple idea one simple story arc
but the more you think about it the more
you start to realize every story I've
heard seems to fit this pattern every
film you've been to every play you've
watched every book you've read maybe
that computer game that you enjoyed
playing Desire obstacles struggle
success or defeat just think from over
there Star Wars and then there's Game of
Thrones and the archers and then there's
that one with that guy in from that TV
show and is as your life
and it's my life desire obstacles
struggle success or defeat this isn't
this isn't some movie trope that's made
up by some Hollywood mogul to sell mega
films to millions this is the story of
humanity this is the story of what it
means to be alive of what it means to be
you what it means to be me the reason
why we can relate to story so well it's
because we sympathize with the
characters we feel their pain their
struggle and we struggle with them but
it's very difficult to emotionally
connect with volumes of composite solids
feeling sympathy with our surroundings
allows us to boot up very primitive
parts of our brain that brilliant
brilliant scientists have shown are
crucial in memory formation memory
storage and later retrieval of memory
does that sound a lot like teaching and
learning if we could get all of those
benefits of stories and we'll be
brilliant teachers but it's difficult to
emotionally invest in maths and that's
where we can cheat we can hijack
narrative structure and really present
any information at all we want within
that structure and in doing so we can
hijack all of the benefits of emotional
engaging with the subject matter and
improve memory formation that narrative
structure brings with it
now for this next part I'm going to need
some help from mayor a couple of
volunteers
so here I've got a dog Julius and please
be kind because I'm a maths teacher and
not a puppeteer now Julius how are you
doing oh I'm doing all right espares
say hello to the audience Julius hello
audience a say hello to Julius audience
yeah very good very good
and a Julius is like all great dogs from
Liverpool dogs home you know because
long live Merseyside and then over on
this hand I have a cat Caesar and like
all cats he's pretty evil so Caesar say
hello to the audience now I hate the
audience yeah they could Cesar thank you
and now Julius yeah you've said that you
felt okay but you didn't sound okay I'm
not really I'm very very very very sad
Julius why are you so sad the cat has
been bullying me have you been bullying
him yeah well he's a stupid dog why is
he stupid but he doesn't even know if
his kettles gonna fit in our house
Julius you got a new kennel oh it's so
great it's I bought it off eBay and it's
got a cube at the bottom and a pillow
minute that's up its gonna look dead
beautiful but I think of all of the
wrong size
Oh Julius ah if if we helped you would
that make you happy oh you wouldn't
believe it the mums coming in an hour
well duelist I reckon with a little bit
of help we might be able to show this
cat that he's wrong and maybe we could
work out if your kennels going to fit in
your house now by way of a show of hands
anybody here that would be willing to if
I did the maths help Julius work out if
his kennels going to fit in the house
all right because that's how you get
children to care about calculating the
volumes of composite solids thank you
you